how has the debate over reagan's
policies evolved into today
when reagan was was making the case for
basically they called it the reagan
revolution because it was a real
departure from the way the federal
government had been
existing in american life the debate had
mostly been between democrats and
republicans over to how best manage the
government ronald reagan came in and
said no just get government out of the
conversation
that has continued to bounce along in
politics
there was the most major fight
on those lines with newt gingrich and
president bill clinton since then there
have been pockets of it but the appetite
for deficit reduction for shrinking
government in order to
make sure that the bills are paid by
government has kind of gone out of favor
in washington it was a very big deal
during the 90s and during the first 10
years
of this century but
it has not really been as much a part of
the conversation
in politics as it once was it once
dominated the way people talked about
government now there are other things
that are taking the conversation away